наймасованіші обстріли Києва з боку
Росії починаючи з 24 лютого в понеділок
вранці вибухи лунали також у Дніпрі
Житомирі Хмельницькому Тернополі Вінниці
Кривому Розі Львів Обухові та інших
населених пунктах загалом по всій
території України вранці понеділка Росія
випустила під сотню ракет окрім
масованих ракетних та авіаційних ударів
Росія застосовує ударній безпілотники
ранок важкий маємо справу З терористами
десятки ракет міранських шахіди у них
дві мішені енергооб'єкти по всій нашій
державі вони прагнули паніки і хаосу
хочуть знищити нашу енергосистему вони
безнадійні друге мішень - це люди
спеціально обрали такий час і такі ціни
щоб завдати якнайбільше шкоди за даними
прем'єр-міністра України Дениса шмигаля
внаслідок російських ракетних ударів
пошкоджено як мінімум 11 важливих
інфраструктурних об'єктів у восьми
регіонах в Києві частину областей з
неструмлено
правитель Білорусі Олександр Лукашенко
заявив що він і президент РФ Володимир
Путін домовилися про розгортання
спільного регіонального угруповання
військ як заявив Лукашенко на нараді з
питань безпеки розгортання такого
угруповання викликане загостренням
цитата на західних кордонах союзної
держави Кремлі назвали вибухи в Україні
частиною так званої спеціальної
військової операції Утім багато хто
називає цю атаку реакцією на суботній
підрив Кримського мосту міст який
поєднував Росію з анексованим
українським Кримом символ незаконної
окупації півострова усе сталося за
кілька годин після ювілею Путіна на
думку західних експертів для Росії атака
на Кримський міст важкий удар як
символічний так і військовий
це кульмінація серед українських успіхів
і російських невдач атака на міст має як
символічне так і військово-стратегічне
значення символічно тому що цей міст
відображає претензії Росії на владу на
володіння Кримом у військово
стратегічному сенсі це важливий маршрут
постачання військової техніки палива та
особового складу
про Символізм і чи не сакральність цього
мосту для Путіна говорить і військовий
експерт Майк Мартін із Лондона
цей міст відкривав особисто Путін це
справжній символ для нього і руйнування
мосту сталося саме тоді коли і так у
Москві починають маневрувати лунають
звинувачення на адресу військової групи
Вагнер особисто Путіна так звана гра у
пошук винних розпочалася і такий
символічний удар українців ще більше
посилить те що відбувається офіційно
Київ не взяв на себе відповідальність за
інцидент Український президент у своєму
щоденному зверненні лише наголосив що на
Кримському півострові 8 жовтня було
хмарно сьогодні на території нашої
держави був
не було більшою мірою
[музика]
близько 20 градусів тепла і Сонця на
жаль в Криму було хмарно Хоча і теж
тепло але яким не були хмари українці
знають що робити і знають що наше
майбутнє воно сонячне це майбутнє без
окупантам на всі наші території зокрема
і в Криму радник голови офісу
Зеленського Михайло Подоляк спочатку у
Твіттері заявив Крим міст початок усе
незаконне має бути зруйновано усе
вкрадене повернуто Україні усе російське
окупаційне вигнане
а згодом від пропустив що вибух був
організований міністерством оборони
Росії нібито Таким чином відомство Шойгу
кидає тінь не ФСБ і перемикає увагу зі
своїх невдач на фронті за версією
російських посадовців вибух вантажівки
на Керченському мості організований
Україною
американська газета нью-йорк Таймс
посилаючись на анонімного
високопосадовця пише що атака на
Кримський міст була організована
спецслужбами України Майк Мартін вважає
що за атакою може стояти лише Київ
це Україна А хто ще Але насправді таке
вже було і раніше ви пам'ятаєте удари по
російських авіабазах у Криму та по
складах постачання за стилем вони схожі
на удари по Кримському мосту це були
неракетні удари ймовірно це було атаки
Спецназу або партизанські атаки Україна
відкидала свою причетність до них в
принципі це те чим займається Росія
протягом 20 років якщо щось відбувається
То Росія Каже ми не знаємо Хто це зробив
в якомусь сенсі українці просто роблять
так само тобто відтворюють дії росіян
вони зробили щось це точно вони але
потім вони кажуть о ми не знаємо Хто це
зробив Хто б це міг бути
російська армія продовжуватиме руйнувати
житлові будинки та інфраструктуру в
Україні вважає гергарт мангот оскільки
на полі бою Росія не може дати
адекватної Віті чи зсуньки я думаю що
після того як тиск на військове та
цивільне керівництво Росії в останні
тижні значно посилився з'явилося багато
розмов про брехню про Потьомкінські села
які є російською армією чи може Путін не
завдати жорсткого удару у відповідь
ймовірно це будуть неядерні удари по
критично важливі інфраструктурі в
Україні він не може залишити цей без
відповіді а якщо говорити про наступ на
полі бою Росія зараз відповісти не в
змозі єдине що залишається це атака на
критичної інфраструктуру
Кремль використовуватиме підрив
керченського мосту в своїх інтересах
впевнений політолог Миколи Петров
Путін сьогодні загнаний у кут і очевидно
що наступним його кроком буде завда
якомога болючіших ударів уже не
по-український армії яка перекриє в
контурнаступ росіян а по цивільним
особам і цивільні інфраструктурі
масована ракетна Атака Росії на Україну
в понеділок вже викликала засуджені
європейських політиків Утім чи отримає
Україна додатковий сучасне озброєння
Густав гресель вважає зараз для цього
Найкращий момент
цього тижня має відбутися чергова
Зустріч міністрів у форматі Rammstein
щодо оборонної підтримки України її
сподіваюся що попередні обмеження на
постачання зброї в Україні будуть заняті
раніше протиповітряна оборона не надто
обговорювалися у цьому європейці та
американці були досить відвертими щодо
можливої заміни українських винищувачів
на західні тут все ще є перепони І
звісно щодо деяких наземних бойових
систем зокрема БМП бойових танків
речник німецького уряду штефенхедиш
трайд повідомив що термінове засідання
Великої сімки присвячена ракетним ударам
Росії по території України відбудеться у
вівторок 11 жовтня на терміновому
засіданні виступить і Зеленський